Mình sẽ ghi mình lãnh nào tình, đồng chiến thình văn đã người lời chiếc buồn
đồng viên gia đình vừa quà đau thường mất mát, còn địa của sống.
Đồng chiến đình ngày chính quyền điều phương quan thăm,
hỗ trợ gia đình đang lẽ các nạn nhân được tổ chức chú quan.
Còn bối lại, tổ giống phố, các bối giữa,
có thể kế cả hẹn tham chức địa.
Vào cuộc để mọi người quan tham.
Làm xà mối lúc, tăng ra bối lúc, tăng ra bối lối.
Cổng dự kịt thầy là dạy ký cây tụt tụt.
Vào cuộc đường giống, trời gia đình.
Để làm sao mà khắc phục.
Khắc phục cóm, không giữ cà được.
Cứ hình hả đảng lòng mà gở quá.
Mà lại chúng ngày chính người tham người thần của mình.
Lòng sao không lực sự lý dành mi Minh,
để có làm người thương lưu khó.
Để kịt thầy chiếc xè, có khăn bối ra đình.
Đồng chiến, viên thình văn đã chào bối mấy chủ đồng,
cùi bàn như dần tình nắc lắc.
Hỗ trợ ra đình để lọ hậu xử cho các nạn nhân và chăm sóc chó nhỏ, mát tôi.